We cross our fingers for luck.
We've been doing it for centuries.
But why?
Originally, the gesture
needed two people.
It was an ancient Pagan custom
for people to cross fingers
with each other.
They believed their wishes
would be kept safe
at the point where their fingers
crossed, until they came true.
This idea of capturing good fortune
also explains the practice
of tying string around a finger.
For Celts and Anglo Saxons,
it would literally tether
good luck to a person.
The gesture also has roots
within Christianity.
When faced with persecution,
early Christians
would cross their fingers
to invoke the power
of Christ's crucifixion.
And in a secret handshake,
they would cross fingers
with fellow Christians
before gathering together
in safety for Mass.
The handshake made the
Christian symbol of the ichthus,
or sign of the fish.
It's thought that Christians
who were persecuted
would cross their fingers
to absolve themselves
from the lies
they told to their tormentors.
And that is why we cross our fingers
behind our back
when making a promise
we don't intend to keep.
In England, in the 16th Century,
people crossed their fingers
to protect themselves
from evil coughs and sneezes.
In the 1787 book of popular
superstitions
it recommended keeping your fingers
crossed after walking under a ladder
until you see a dog.
But it is the gesture's association
with good luck
that has stood the test of time.
A recent University College of London
study found that crossing fingers
confuses the way our brains
process pain signals,
actually reducing painful sensations.
And if that's true, then that would
be a bit of good luck for everyone.
Thanks for watching.
Don’t forget to subscribe! :)